dans les déserts d'amérique du nord ce
petit scarabée passe inaperçu muni d'une
armure à toute épreuve il a un an digne
d'un film de super héros le scarabée
cure assez diabolique il est presque
indestructible
une équipe de chercheurs en ont fait la
démonstration
même en lui roulant dessus avec une
voiture le scarabée est restée intacte
le squelette externe de ce coléoptère
est capable de supporter jusqu'à trente
neuf mille fois son poids c'est comme si
un homme de 70 kg pouvait supporter 2007
130 tonnes
pour percer le secret du scarabée les
chercheurs ont eu recours à de la
microtomographie par rayons x une
technique d'imagerie en trois dimensions
sa résistance incroyable et du acl
externe appelé des élytres avec
l'évolution cl en fusionner elles se
sont imbriquées l'une dans l'autre
exactement comme les pièces d'un
casse-tête
résultat il ne peut plus voler par
contre cette géométrie particulière rang
cesel très difficile à briser mais ce
n'est pas tout
les i litres sont aussi composé de
plusieurs couches laminée sous des
forces très importante ces couches se
sépare les unes des autres
on si les élites se déforme lentement au
lieu de se briser abruptement ce
scarabée peut aussi s'aplatir sous la
pression cela lui permet de pouvoir
glisser par des cachettes étroite
la solidité du cuirassé diabolique est
tellement impressionnante que les
chercheurs veulent maintenant sont
inspirés pour améliorer la sécurité des
avions
avec une telle armure on peut se
demander maintenant de quel danger il a
dû se protéger
[Musique]